[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
j'ai voulu ce soir rendre hommage à mon
ami
à notre ami
gaspard
j'ai choisi de le faire sous la forme
d'une lettre
que voici
madame
je vous adresse cette lettre sans même
vous connaître semble bien vous
connaître
dehors derrière la fenêtre de ma chambre
dans le bois où je me suis réfugié la
neige virevoltent dans l'air elle est
transfiguré par la lumière du soleil et
le vent s'acharne à l'abattre en neige
folle nous appelons chez nous
poudreuse
de grands conifères s'élève devant moi
recouvert d'un dépôt blanc très loin
l'hiver est calme
tout à coup après une amorce brutale
je savais en venant chercher ici
isolement
que j'allais commencer à penser et
écrire sur gaspard j'avais déjà
auparavant écrit pour gaspard j'avais
écrit à gaspard
mais je n'avais pas écrit sur gaspard et
apparat pour un article une entrevue un
prix honorifique croyez bien que je
n'avais aucune intention de le faire
le jour de sa mort j'ai revu à la
recherche évidemment de sa compagnie
plusieurs de ses films
dont un long dimanche de fiançailles
l'espoir de mathilde de retrouver manech
sur ses musiques de badalamenti sur ses
fonds de blé flav de grand-champ qui
s'excitent
s'opposait à mon chagrin
elle allait le retrouver
elle
peut-être à vaiges intentionnellement
décidé que ce fait nous confirmerait les
choses
que l'on refuse de voir que je refuse
encore à ce jour ce soir
par exemple
devoir de croire
mais je ne suis pas venu ici
parler étonnamment de la carrière de
gaspard ulliel
jeu pourrait dresser la liste d'exploits
et de faits d'armes brillant
de passage étoilé parmi les stars de la
riviera de la riviera patrons
d'industrie de campagne
mais quel effet lénifiant pourrait bien
avoir ces choses là sur la plaie béante
de son départ
je n'ai pu m'empêcher de songer qu'il
aurait détesté ce type des loges
il aurait perçu je pense dans cette
glorification
un manque d'élégance
et il était très élégant
car sa carrière sa fiche d'elle-même
à travers les c'est qui le chante les
articles qui le louange et tous les
rôles qui lui survivent
son talent
nous le possédons encore
et ça
personne pourra nous l'enlever
c'est le privilège d'être célèbre est un
acteur de sa lumière que de pouvoir
compter sur la pour qu'ils nous estampes
dans la pérennité
alors que d'autres deuil
important pour certains demeurent
inconnus de tous ou deviennent si vite
évanescent
c'est tout un monde qui a pleuré aspar
c'est tout un monde qui le pleurent
encore
ce soir je souhaitais vous partager deux
choses
à 16 ou 17 ans
j'avais écrit un premier scénario
on a eu tôt fait d'écarter celui là
dans ce film qui s'appelait les hell
rose
il y avait une figure centrale
d'adolescents perdu qui se cherchait ce
sont est très seul qui cachait au monde
ses préférences en fin de premier acte
un ange apparaissait à ce jeune homme et
le guider vers la lumière
bon
c'était la fulgurance la naïveté des
premiers écrits où l'on emprunte tout ce
qu'on aime et écrite c'est tous ceux qui
pensent différemment de nous
seul contre tous
mélange dans ce désordre avait tout
compte fait un beau rôle je l'avais
écrit je vous le donne en mille
pour gaspard
ça ne s'était jamais rendu à lui du
moins je ne pense pas
j'avais également écrit un autre rôle
pour lui
plus tard et ça n'avait pas marché là
non plus
une autre figure lumineuse bien que
moins angélique dont la bienveillance
sauvé un personnage encore une fois
perdu des années plus tard je lui
demandais d'être louis
dans l'adaptation de juste la fin du
monde de jean luc lagarce
cet ange l'a déchue et à qui la vie
avait coupé les ailes
se sacrifiait pour protéger sa famille
lors de notre première lecture
les horaires conflictuelle de tout un
chacun
déboucher sur une impasse qui l'avait
débrouiller en me disant ceci
fait l'un sans moi
xavier la lecture après tout
je suis celui qui ne parle pas je suis
celui qui écoute
j'aurais bien l'occasion de me rattraper
et il se rattrapa
gaspard et est souvent celui qui écoute
ou qui ne parle pas
on a parlé de sa discrétion de cette
douceur
du mystère qu'il n'occupe civette pas de
son propre aveu intentionnellement
mais on a pu par lui
ce que je suis désolé pardon on a pu
parler de son éloquence
gelé tant entendu exprimer son amour du
métier de la vie des belles choses dans
une langue soignée qui célèbre la
musicalité la rareté des mots pendant
que plusieurs se faisait un devoir de
parler en premier gaspard distiller déjà
une pensée
regard plus abouti
plus ciselée un peu comme celui qu'ils
posent à la fin de saint laurent
de son ami bertrand bonello
dans cet instant où il lorgne la caméra
est pas ses yeux précisément sur la
situation
qui est la vie et sur notre âme aussi il
semble avoir compris quelque chose qui à
tous nous échappe encore possiblement
j'ai choisi de vous adresser cette
lettre madame
parce que je ne savais pas autrement qu
en vous disant à quel point je
l'admirais et les mais
je ne savais pas comment lui rendre un
véritable hommage
je crois qu'il aurait aimé savoir que
j'ai écrit cette lettre en écoutant une
pièce de la furent arnalds intitulé thuy
l'arbre il l'aurait écouté
mieux
nous l'aurions écouter ensemble
sans exclure tous ceux qui l'ont aimé
et sa famille c'est à vous qu'il me
semblait naturel décrire ce soir avoue
que j'ai tout de suite pensé ce matin là
car l'amour d'une mère est plus fort que
tout
je le crois
plus fort que la vie
plus fort que l'art même
est plus fort certainement
que la mort
merci zizou les
[Applaudissements]